let's go next to our caller from the seven
five, seven area code.
Who's calling today from seven five, seven.
Hey, David, his day.
Did you say this is James Jay Jay.
What's going on Jay?
What's up man?
Amen.
Bernie supporter.
I'm really hoping for 2020 opened.
Like Biden didn't screw it up, but I also
like, you know, Andrew Yang and toes together.
Like I really loved their policies.
They'll come down to the wire, they don't
have a chance winning the nomination.
Do you think, uh, Bernie's to put like Toci
as vice president?
Maybe Andrew Yang is like a secretary of treasury
or something, you know, something like that.
It would be, I mean, secretary, well you gotta
win the nomination before we start thinking
about secretary of the treasury.
I even think it's a little early to start
thinking about VP, but I listen, Bernie Warren
I like in a lot of ways, although I think
strategically it may not be the best thing,
but I'm trying not to think about that.
I mean we're just getting ahead of ourselves,
but the idea of Bernie supplemented Elizabeth
Warren's slightly more moderate origins and
very pro entrepreneurship as we've pointed
out this week on the show.
Um, I, I think that that would be very, very
interesting, but I think it's just too early
to really make that call.
We got to see who wins the primary first.
Yeah, true.
Yeah.
Just holding like, you know, the course of
this or no, know how that goes and well, we
hope they learn from like 2016 but can't hold
your breath.
Yeah, no, I know what you mean.
For sure.
Uh, but yeah, we'll, I mean we'll have plenty
of time to sort that out.
I, I assure you.
Yeah.
All right, thanks.
Okay, great.
Appreciate the phone call.
Thank you.